let's listen to to what uh joe biden is
saying
we knew this was gonna go on
good evening
look we feel good about where we are
we really do
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in the mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of tallying
the votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
[Applause]
but we're feeling good we're feeling
good about where we are
we believe one of the nets has suggested
we've already won
arizona but we're confident about
arizona that's a turnaround
we also just called it from minnesota
and we're still in the game in georgia
although
that's not what we expected
and we're feeling real good about
wisconsin and michigan
and by the way it's going to take time
to count the votes we're going to win
pennsylvania
[Applause]
we're talking to folks in philly
allegheny county scranton
and they're really encouraged by the
turnout and what they see
look you know we could know the results
as early as tomorrow morning but it may
take a little longer as i've said all
along
it's not my place for donald trump's
place to declare who's won this election
that's the decision of the american
people but i'm optimistic about this
outcome
and i want to thank every one of you who
came out
and voted in this election and by the
way chris coons and the democrats
congratulations here in delaware
hey john you're the gov yeah like the
whole
team man you've done a great job i'm
grateful
to the poll workers to our volunteers
our canvassers
everyone who participated in this
democratic process
and i'm grateful to all of my supporters
here in delaware and all across the
nation
thank you thank you thank you and folks
you heard me say it before every time i
walk out of my grandpa's house up in
scranton and he yelled joey
keep the faith and my grandmom when she
was laughing oh no joey spread it
keep the faith guys we're gonna win this
thank you thank you thank you
your patience is great let's walk over
here
[Applause]
all right joe biden there making uh a
statement
in wilmington delaware saying that he's
confident
that uh his campaign has won arizona
feels good about
wisconsin michigan and pennsylvania he
says
reminding the public the world
that it's not his or uh president
trump's place to work to call this
election until
every vote is counted let's go live now
to
al jazeera's mike hanna who's in
wilmington delaware so after staying
tight-lipped
for the past few hours mike hannah
finally
not only do we have uh the uh the
campaign
uh making a statement we have the man
himself joe biden coming out oh he's
hang on he's just come back to the
podium
mike hang on a second no he's just
saying thank you and goodbye sorry mike
um yeah so what did you make of the
statement
midnight here joe biden coming out as
you say after
an evening in which no statement came
out of the campaign joe biden drove up
here in his motorcade behind me to the
convention center where his campaign is
based
i got up there and made that short
statement he said
on at least three occasions there we
feel good about where we
are he said we are optimistic about
where we are
uh biden calling on his supporters to be
patient
making very clear that it will take a
while for all these results
to fall into place however adamant that
arizona will go his way adamant as well
that there's a strong likelihood of
wisconsin and michigan and pennsylvania
but these three states uh very clearly
the result is going to take a while
possibly not even in the early morning
maybe even later
pennsylvania for example is only
beginning to count the mail in votes now
it has until friday to count those
particular votes
so certainly this is a long drawn-up
process
joe biden appearing here at his campaign
headquarters
clearly to call on his supporters for
patience
but at the same time the message he was
giving to his supporters
keep the faith he says keep the faith as
you can hear the music now
blaring behind me finally we've heard
something from
the biden campaign and that is a message
from joe biden
one of optimism one are saying we feel
good about where we
are in wilmington delaware so we've
heard
from uh joe biden himself meanwhile
president trump has uh issued
a statement our white house
correspondent kimberly halcott is there
uh kimberly what's he been saying
uh yeah well i am pulling up that
statement uh that i know that he has
made on twitter
and i'm trying to find it as we talk
about it
uh so just keep bearing with me here but
what i can tell you is
they're not going to be sitting well i
can tell you he said he says
you know when of course he says we're up
big
we're up big but they're trying to steal
the election
we will never let we will never let them
do it
trump predicts big win and he says he's
going to speak later
tonight
many thanks for that yes absolutely we
have been watching and waiting
for the president we know that he has
been in the
residence he's been in the east room
he's been watching this
we had expected that he would have
spoken by now but it sounds like that is
still
imminent the president likes to get the
last word
and so it looks like that is the case
again
what i can tell you is there is anger
inside the white house right now adrian
because
uh they're furious uh the campaign as
well as the white house staff that
fox news has called arizona
for the rival joe biden
and as a result they believe that the
media may even be complicit in trying to
help joe biden at least that is the
statement
that has been issued from the campaign
they sent an email saying
the fake news media will refuse to call
this presidential race
to keep us from winning now as we have
been talking throughout the night
in-person voting favorite donald trump
early
mail-in voting favored joe biden that's
why
you hear joe biden talking about every
vote being counted
we know that there are some states where
the accounting could go on
for many more days and this is not good
news for donald trump
and that's why he's tweeting that things
should be stopped on election day but he
has tried to challenge us in the courts
and it has been unsuccessful so far
this was a tactic that we knew was
coming didn't we
this had been speculated upon if if
things looked tight if it was going to
go
if we didn't know the result on on
tuesday night the early hours of
wednesday morning and it dragged on into
into late wednesday
we knew that the president was going to
do something
like this maybe even get the lawyers
involved
absolutely i mean this is a page from
donald trump's playbook that goes back
decades
he's a fighter and he doesn't give up
and he believes that
uh often he can win things in the court
so
uh there is a very high probability that
even if this ultimately is decided for
joe biden that
there will be a legal challenge and if
it goes all the way to the supreme court
you start to understand why donald trump
was so interested in
pushing through that appointment of amy
coney barrett
because now the supreme court makeup
leans in his
favor we've certainly seen this back in
2000 where the supreme court got
involved
it is possible this could happen again
there are still so many scenarios before
we get there
we haven't even got the original tally
of votes counted and we still
potentially could have a recount there's
so many ways this could play out
but you know already that the campaign
and the white house and the president
are considering their options when all
is said and done i mean
there's very little the president
himself can can do tonight other than
shout about it on twitter
which is what he has been doing as you
pointed out and saved me there by
reading that tweet
uh what we also know though and our
producer on the ground
uh has been monitoring what's happening
at the white house
all the lights are on you can see behind
me that there is a lot of activity still
going on
the feeling is is that they are going to
try and make sure that every vote is
counted
in their favor as well but the bottom
line is in some major cities
the voting uh count has stopped for the
night
and will resume in the morning we're
about i believe it's
yeah almost 1am here in on the east
coast of the united states
so in cities like philadelphia in
detroit they're not counting at the
moment they're not going to pick that
back up
until the next day and what we also know
is that those cities lean in favor of
joe biden so even if they do continue
counting
that's not necessarily good for donald
trump that's why he's so adamant trying
to stop it but again
that has not been successful so far all
right kimberly
i'm glad to see that the president
corrected the spelling of polls
uh let's go back to mike hannah in in
wilmington
delaware uh what will the biden campaign
be making of that mike
well we haven't heard any reaction from
the supporters at this particular point
although you heard
a number of them they're parked in their
vehicles this very much
a measured distance a social distance
campaign headquarters but clearly some
cheers and support for joe biden as he
made that statement
now this as i said is way past half past
midnight
uh the convoy arriving here joe biden
making this
surprise appearance after an evening in
which we heard nothing at all
from any member of the campaign uh joe
biden saying in the course of yesterday
afternoon that when he's got something
to say
he'll come out and say it well now he
did have something to say
he came out and he said it and what he's
saying to his supporters
is keep the faith on the one hand it's
absolutely
adamant that he's looking for victory in
contested states like arizona wisconsin
michigan
and very very importantly pennsylvania
but he also called for patience these
results are going to take a long time to
come
and what we are seeing as well from
president trump's immediate tweet there
in the wake of joe biden's comments
that this is now after an evening of
relative calm certainly as far as the
two contestants are concerned this is
beginning to erupt a little bit
first we got the statement from biden
now we've got the tweets from trump
uh president trump clearly picking up on
this issue of the delayed vote count in
pennsylvania
he had been absolutely against the
question of mailed in ballots throughout
the campaign
his campaign brought it to the supreme
court in the end
the supreme court ruling only last week
that in pennsylvania
officials have got until friday to count
the votes
five o'clock friday afternoon and
certainly at this particular point given
the vast amount
of mail-in votes that have not been
counted in pennsylvania
it may well stretch right up to that
last moment
so all of a sudden after an evening in
which always quiet from the candidates
this is beginning to erupt a little bit
along with the music here behind me
is the biden campaign got an army of
lawyers ready to fight this
which of course the trump campaign has
yes indeed well the biting campaign does
just like
the trump campaign will have its legal
people in place
but the key issue here has already been
decided on
by the supreme court of the united
states to appoint
the trump campaign on two separate
occasions
brought a case saying that the vote in
pennsylvania could not be
extended they brought it originally in
the middle of october
and then when there's a possibility of a
new supreme court justice taking her
place on the bench
to be able to decide on the issue
increasing the conservative majority in
the court
the lawyers brought it again however any
kind of barrett did not sit on that
particular case because she wasn't
properly briefed
so essentially the court was split which
meant that it goes back
and allows the officials in pennsylvania
until friday
to count that being said though there's
another little legal twist in all of
this
because a number of justices on the
supreme court
at least three of them indicated that
they may revisit
that decision after election day
there's a possibility a remote
possibility
but the judges have made it clear that
they could revisit that
decision and halt the count in
pennsylvania there's a lot of ways that
this can go from here
certainly a highly complex and a highly
tense situation
beginning to emerge president trump has
been going on for months about being
opposed
to the extension of the vote to allow
extra time to count
mail-in vote or absentee votes this is
now coming to a head
over the next 24 36 hours but certainly
as it stands at the moment pennsylvania
has until friday
5 p.m to count all the votes that have
reached them
that are postmarked november 3rd
and those votes will be counted and as
we've seen from the results throughout
the evening
mail-in voting absentee voting has
heavily favored the democrats
in-person voting voting in the polls on
the day
has heavily voted the republicans this
is why this results have been
so difficult to follow because they've
been coming in lumps
in some places the early voting was
counted first
in other places it hasn't been counted
yet so this skewed results we are
getting all the time with
one candidate suddenly leaping ahead the
other contender
then leaping over we saw biden leaving
a leading in a number of states in the
early vote
where the absentee ballot was counted
first such as florida
immediately the in-person voting was
counted that
began to change so a very complicated
situation to follow
and certainly it's a result that very
clearly now
may take days certainly until friday
before we get a clearer indication of
what
is happening